hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
cell types to targets
single cell rna sequencing for drug
discovery i am alexis krause of
labyrinths and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinths and
sponsored by
10x genomics for more information about
our sponsor
please visit their website at
10xgenomics.com
so let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting
as many questions as you want at any
time you want during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click on the send button if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
i'd like to now introduce our presenter
dr sarah middleton
computational biologist at gsk
for a complete biography on our
presenter please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen dr middleton
you you may now begin your presentation
thank you very much for the introduction
uh my name is sarah middleton and i'm a
computational biologist in the
functional genomics group at gsk
today i'd like to talk about how single
cell rna-seq can be used for drug
discovery as well as some of the
challenges that i think we are having
that are preventing us from using this
technology to its full potential at the
moment
so i've designed this talk with drug
discovery in mind of course because that
is my focus
but i think that the concepts that i'll
cover today are really not specific to
drug discovery and in fact can be
really relevant for anyone who's
interested in disease biology
so to start and just to get everyone on
the same page i do want to take a moment
to
go over the drug discovery pipeline
because i know it's not something that
everyone is familiar with
so drug discovery pipeline is not
something that is really set in stone
and even within a given company it can
change
it's also changed quite a bit over time
in fact but i think
at least in today's day this day and age
um
it generally follows this flow so we'll
start off with
target identification and validation
this is where we're trying to select a
protein
that we will eventually target with a
molecule
that we hope will actually have a
therapeutic effect on the disease
once we have selected the protein we can
then go to compound screening and lead
optimization
candidate selection so on these are the
steps where we are actually trying to
select
and optimize the molecule that will bind
to
our protein and hopefully have the
therapeutic effect whether it's
inhibiting the function of that protein
or activating it and so on
once we have a molecule in hand we can
then move on to preclinical development
and so this encompasses a pretty wide
range of activities actually
but mostly geared around trying to
better understand
the safety of the molecule uh the dosing
strategy
as well as how the molecule is actually
interacting with the protein what is the
mechanism of action
and how is modulating the target
actually
uh what kind of effect is that actually
producing and so
usually this will involve a lot of in
vitro and vivo studies
so once the molecule has passed safety
standards and
seems to be showing at least potential
efficacy we can finally move on to
human clinical trials if it passes this
then it becomes a successful medicine
which is great
um and then there will often be a stage
of um
post-market research where we'll you
know look at things sort of we
uh are there certain patient populations
who are responding better to this
treatment or worse
are there other diseases where this
molecule might be useful
and things like that so as i mentioned
i'm a computational biologist
and i think this is a pretty fun job to
have in the pharma industry because you
get to work
across the entire drug discovery
pipeline really our job is to work with
large data sets
and usually this will be omix data sets
so transcriptome
genome so on and so forth and really we
just go wherever
the omix data is this could involve you
know working on things like
differential expression between disease
and healthy
analyzing the output of functional
screens doing pathway analysis
network analysis sometimes we work on
things like biomarker identification
and output from clinical trials and
things like that
so really a diverse set of things we can
do
and in particular i think transcriptome
data such as microarray and bulk rna-seq
have become pretty well-established
tools in pharma for
answering various questions along this
pipeline in particular
for target identification target
validation and preclinical development
however i think single cell rna-seq on
the other hand
is much newer technology and we're
really just beginning to
explore how we can actually utilize it
for drug discovery
so what i like to do in the first half
of my talk is
just give a very high level overview of
some of the opportunities that i see
for single cell rna-seq and drug
discovery i want to say up front that
this will definitely not be
a comprehensive review of all the ways
that single cell reac could be used
just for the sake of time i'm going to
focus mostly on you know my own
experiences which are mostly in the
early target discovery space
however i will at least touch on some
examples in later development that i
think are particularly exciting
so we'll start at the earliest stages of
the pipeline which is target discovery
so as i mentioned before the goal of
target discovery is essentially to try
and identify
proteins that when modulated through a
molecule such as an antibody or a small
molecule
will produce a therapeutic effect for
the disease and also be safe for human
use
so of course we do have various assays
that will allow us if we have a molecule
already
whether to assess if that molecule is
likely to be safe
and efficacious for a particular disease
using you know various
in future amiibo models however getting
to that stage of where we actually have
a molecule and then doing all these
tests
is very time consuming and expensive and
so
really our goal in target discovery is
to
narrow down the field of targets as much
as possible so that
we're really zeroing in the ones that
are most likely to be
successful and that way we can focus our
resources and time
on just those most likely candidates and
hopefully through that get to a medicine
more quickly
so then the question becomes you know
how do we effectively predict what
targets are going to be
most likely successful for a given
disease
so i think there's a huge range of
different ways we do target discovery
basically um i'm going to focus mostly
on the you know the context of bulk
rna-seq and what we've done so far
so generally you know in what we might
do
if we're considering using rna
sequencing as a tool for identifying
targets is we might have say a healthy
just
a cohort and disease cohort we do rna
sequencing on them
and we compare them using differential
expression and this can help identify
genes that are going up and down disease
and help us understand the pathways that
are involved and therefore
help us zero in on targets
we may also have within the disease
cohort information on disease
progression
if we have this it's really useful
because then we can look at how the
expression of the given gene
is correlated with the disease activity
score disease progression so on and so
forth
this is useful because it gives us that
little bit of extra information that
tells us
you know this gene is actually changing
along with the disease progression
and there therefore may be modulating
that gene will have an effect on the
disease progression
another thing we can do is if we have
known disease subtypes
we can also look at the expression of
genes across those subtypes which should
help us better understand
you know what was different about these
subtypes um and depending on how it's
set up will give us different
information about the disease
so now i think for this audience i don't
need to convince you that you know bulk
learning speak while useful
is also limited in the sense that it
gives you an average
of what is probably a very heterogeneous
population of cells
in your sample and really with bulk
rnaseq
you will only identify signals that are
either very dramatic
so if you're comparing healthy disease
for example very dramatic changes in
expression
may show up or changes that occur in a
very dominant cell type that's making up
a lot of the sample
you may be able to detect those however
we're going to miss a lot of things that
are more subtle
and so this is where single pharmacy can
really help we can break down
this heterogeneous pool of cells into
cell pipes and then look at changes of
expression
within those cell types so this can be
great when you know
for most cell types we're not having a
change in a particular gene it's really
only even one cell type that that gene
is changing
in addition we can actually go even
further and this is part of what's great
about single cellernasek is because you
don't have to define upfront
you know all the subtypes that you want
to look into you can go fairly deep
without having to set up a complex you
know panel to sort those cells or
anything like that
and so we could say we think that
there's something interesting going on
in c4t cells we can actually go
even deeper and look at quite a number
of subtypes of c4t cells
and again we might see that it's really
only one subtype
that is showing a change of a particular
gene
and this is really powerful because you
know a lot of these subtypes are quite
rare
and you really there's no way you're
going to see that on a bulk or an ac
example unless you've enriched it
already for what you're what you think
you're going to see
a single cell already gives you
opportunity to look at this in a little
bit of a more unbiased manner
so i think this is a really intuitive
way of understanding how
single cell rna-seq can add value to how
we're already using bulk iron you seek
in pharma however there's actually
additional things we can do with single
learning seek
that sort of take a different approach
altogether
and one of those types of approaches i
want to talk about today is a cell type
focused strategy
so what we're going to do here is
instead of directly trying to identify
genes that are changing
disease we're going to first start by
trying to identify the cell types that
are changing in disease once we've
identified those cell types
we can then look within each cell type
individually and look for altered
pathways and targets
between healthy and disease and then we
can
also prioritize within those pathways
once we have those two pieces of
information
we're really well set up to do our
functional assays in validation because
we've already identified a cell type
that we think is relevant and the
pathways and you know mechanistically
what we think is going wrong in that
cell type
which is really helpful for designing a
good assay to test our
hypotheses so i want to go a little bit
more into depth into each of these steps
so as you might imagine a crucial part
of this is actually doing a good job of
identifying what cell type is relevant
to the disease
and there's several different strategies
we could take here to do that
and this is not going to be exhaustive
there's probably a lot of other creative
ways you can do this but these are just
some
simple ways that you might consider as a
first pass
the first method to identify cell types
related to disease would be to look at
cell
changes in cell type proportions so we
can think about those same three
experiments experimental designs i
talked about
and now we can try to look at them in
the context of changes in felt type
fractions or proportions
so if we're comparing healthy versus
disease we might look for cell types
that are specific to disease
or ones that have expanded or depleted
in the
disease state it probably goes without
saying but i think it's important to
note that you know just because we see a
change in disease and a cell type
in disease in terms of proportion this
doesn't necessarily mean that it's
causative of that disease it just means
that that is
you know an observation of something
that's different in the disease
so we do need to interpret this with
care however i think this is a really
useful way of starting to get the
question of you know what might be
relevant
another thing you always have to think
about with proportions is that when one
cell type increases in proportion
of course all the other cell types are
going to decrease right because
everything has to sum to one
and so it can be a little tricky to pick
apart these differences but nonetheless
i think this is a good first pass to try
and figure out
you know what what's changing and what
is relevant
if you have information on disease
progression again we can this is really
useful because we can start to look at
what
cell types are sort of expanding along
with disease severity or you know just
changing in
proportion along with some sort of
measure of severity or progression
again this can give us a little bit more
information on things that maybe
you know start early in disease and
therefore maybe are more related to
causative
more causative for disease or maybe
things that are just tracking with
progression and therefore are related to
progression
if we have information about these
subtypes we can directly look at
association
of the frequency of different cell types
with those subtypes
this is great for trying to understand
you know if if we think there are
very distinct subtypes of disease that
maybe require different treatments
we can start to look at you know what
are the cell types that might explain
those differences and
may be best to target in each of those
subtypes
so another approach we can take let's
say we look at our compare disease to
healthy and we don't see major changes
in cell type proportion
what could be going on is that instead
there's a cell pipe that's changing in
its activation state
so we might see we might look for
signatures of pathogenic activation that
might tell us some more
about what's going wrong another thing
we can do is we can look at cell types
that
are expression genes that we already
know are associated with disease say
from a g-wasp analysis
we can also look just overall what cell
types are changing the most in terms of
gene expression things that change a lot
may have something going on that is
related to the disease
now i think all of these approaches are
very powerful because you're bringing in
your prior knowledge but of course the
drawback is you have to actually have
that prior knowledge in order to utilize
it
nonetheless you can see i'm going to
show some examples you know if you have
some knowledge of for example signatures
that are related to your disease such as
you know things are responding to
interferon or
signature of exhaustion you know you can
overlay this
onto your cell types and see what cell
types are you know
showing that change in state and this
might help you zero in on cell types
that you think are relevant for the
disease
if you have g wash genes already again
this is
a useful tool to help you zero in on
cell types you can see
you know which cell types are expressing
a lot of those g wash genes
or you could see if you compare healthy
versus disease are there certain cell
types where a lot of ghos-related genes
are changing in expression so those
just two different ways of kind of
getting at that question of if we have
genetic information
can we use that to zero in on the cell
type
another way you can think about this is
instead of just looking at individual
cells what might be relevant for the
disease is actually interaction between
cells
there are a number of more recent
methods that actually allow you to start
to
infer this based on single-cell rna-seq
data
and these can be potentially really
interesting to help form these
hypotheses about pairs of cells or
groups of cell types that are
you know together their interaction is
related
to the disease progression
we can also look at trajectory analysis
which lets you see continuous sources of
variation
that might be related to your disease
so whatever method you use at the end
the hope is that you've arrived at some
cell types that you think are related to
the disease
and then what you can do is essentially
differential expression within that cell
type
um identify things that are changing for
that cell type and then use that as
input to pathway network analysis
with uh you know pathway network
analysis is i think challenging
sometimes it doesn't always produce
useful information but if it does it's
really great because
when you have a pathway this gives you
some information
about you know like mechanistically
what's actually going on
and it also gives you an opportunity to
do prioritization
because you can look within that pathway
and say well which you know if
if i see several places where i can
modulate this pathway that
i think will produce a therapeutic
effect i can prioritize the genes that i
think
um show favorable characteristics so in
pharma a lot of things we look at
are things like genetics because it's
been shown that genes with genetic
evidence so gus signals and so on
for a particular disease are more likely
to become successful drug targets
we also look at things like tractability
so is the protein
actually something that we think they
can target with a molecule
not all proteins are actually amenable
to this so we prioritize based on that
otherwise you know we're
really you can have the best gene in the
world but if you can't actually modulate
it anyway
then you're out of luck we also look at
things like
cell type specificity genes that are
specific to a cell type or to a tissue
tend to be safer because basically
you're not going to hit as many things
in the body
and then we can also bring in many other
types of biological knowledge to help us
prioritize
so once you've arrived oh sorry and
another thing i think is really
interesting
um just as a note is that you know you
might decide depending on the cell types
you've identified
in that seem to be related to the
disease you could go for a direct cell
depletion that of course is only um a
good idea for certain cell types but
it's an option that
becomes available when you kind of
zeroed in on the cell type you think is
relevant
so once you've identified you know you
have your cell types you have your
pathways and or targets
then as i said you're really well set up
to do your functional assays and then do
that final prioritization
and validation of the targets um i think
this is really key because
having the right functional assays and
right readouts
is really important for actually you
know getting a good prediction
on what targets are going to eventually
be safe and efficacious
and are more likely to be successful
ultimately
so you know i'd love to give you know
examples of how we're using this but of
course it's challenging in pharma to
share these things at times but i think
there are a lot of good examples in the
literature at least
now that when people have started to
improve upon
our disease understanding based on cell
type information that's gotten from
single cell
so for example i'm showing a paper here
where they looked at a model of
a neurodegeneration and they identified
the disease-associated
microglia subtype and basically by
you know comparing this
disease-associated microglia to other
microglia
they identified some differentially
expressed genes and this helps them
understand better you know how microglia
might progress to this disease state
and form a hypothesis about how the
disease might progress
and you can imagine how this might be
useful then for better target hypotheses
for drug discovery
another more recent example is a study
where they
used brain samples from humans both
controls and
patients with autism spectrum disorder
they did a decent
uh pretty deep um subtyping of their
cells
and then did differential expression in
a cell type specific manner
and they used this then to identify
celtic specific differential expressed
genes that were correlated with the
clinical scores for these patients and
then
this information was used to try and
figure out what cell types were actually
most relevant for the disease and might
be playing an important role
so just another really interesting way
that cell type specific information
was used
so of course there are actually many
other strategies that we use in target
discovery and i'm just going to touch on
two additional ones so the first is
functional screens so here this is where
basically
we usually use crispr or another gene
editing technology
we create a library that will target
various different genes
sometimes the entire genome and we're
going to basically take the strategy of
knocking them out one by one and seeing
what happens and so
we will usually have some kind of
readout
that will tell us something you know but
the readout has to be designed very
carefully to tell us something about how
the function of those cells being
altered by the knockout
and so by doing this we can then
hopefully get a sense of what genes are
playing
a functional role in whatever it is that
we're trying to
profile now you can imagine in order to
get output from this that's actually
relevant to your disease
you need to set it up the right way and
i think a key for that and
i think most people agree is starting
with the right cell type um
of course not all fill types can be
easily you know used for
a functional screen but at least if you
have you know taken this cell type first
approach
and and try to identify the false types
associated with disease
um this can point you in the right
direction for the more optimal cell type
to do your screen in
we can also actually directly use single
cell now for
crispr screens and there's several
methods that have been developed that
allow you to do this and the great thing
about these approaches
is that basically the readout that you
get from the screen is the cell
transcriptome
and so this is a very rich source of
information to better understand the
functional consequence
of whatever perturbation you've
introduced to the cell
finally another strategy that i think is
very important is the genetics driven
strategy so this is where
you know we start with genetics and then
go from there for target identification
and prioritization and you know like as
i mentioned already
you know the reason why this is such a
key approach is because it's already
been shown
several times now that with genetic
evidence are more likely to be
successful drug targets
and so we're enriching basically for
success
i think some ways that single cell can
help with this approach is basically by
allowing you to get more cell pipe
resolution
on whatever information it is you're
using so for example if you're looking
at
gwas signals you can use open chromatin
within single cells or different cell
types to help narrow your focus to those
signals that are most likely to be
relevant
for cell types that you think are
relevant to the disease
you can also do things like single cell
eqtls
as well as cell type derived sorry
single cell derived regulatory networks
which are really interesting and i think
these are these are two areas that are
really
just just beginning to utilize single
cell so
keep an eye on those space as they
develop
so then i also want to just briefly
touch on some ways that we can use
single cell rna-seq and the cell-type
approach for
later development and drug discovery so
one of the
really powerful things you can get out
of when you actually do a clinical trial
is you can profile people before
and after treatment and this could give
us a lot of
really interesting pieces of information
that can help us design
you know better design our medicines and
target the right people
so for one thing you can look at
mechanism of action you can say how does
it feel
how is this treatment affecting each
cell type are there any unexpected
effects
are there any cell types that we're not
expecting to modulate that we are
you can look at mechanisms of resistance
so if you have people who respond and
then people who are not responding
you can see what's different about them
in terms of their cell types
this might suggest combination therapies
because if they're you know we see in
the non-responders that there's some
sort of
other cell type involved then that might
point to
you know an avenue to develop another
treatment for those people
or maybe there's already an existing
treatment that you can bring in as a
immediate combination therapy finally we
can do prediction of response so we can
look at people before they're treated
and see what's different about their
cell types or just their expression
profiles
and say you know does the abundance of a
certain cell type uh
predict response and can we use that to
better you know identify the people that
are most likely to benefit from a
particular treatment
one thing i'm really interested in is
how we can use
single cell and cell type information to
you know help us better stratify
heterogeneous diseases so i think a lot
of diseases are
you know i i think it's common knowledge
a lot of diseases are pretty
heterogeneous and
you know they may actually consist
really of many subtypes of disease or
maybe be sort of a spectrum of disease
one example and i think you know cell
type proportions is one way this
heterogeneity can manifest an example of
this
is been shown for rheumatoid arthritis
that there's at least two subtypes of
people there are those that have
leukocyte-rich ra so these are have a
high proportion of t cells and b
cells and then there's leukocyte poor ra
who have higher proportions of
fibroblasts and monocytes
and actually the leukocyte poor rna
looks a lot more like osteoarthritis
than it does leukocyte-rich
arthritis rheumatoid arthritis
and so i think this is quite a dramatic
difference
and i think it points to the idea that
most likely different kinds of treatment
would benefit these two different groups
of people
and in addition when we look to you know
try and develop those treatments it's
important to take into account the
actual cell types
that are present in these people and you
know maybe if we look more at subtypes
as well we might get an even better
understanding
so what we could do is you know we can
again take cell type proportions and use
this to do
you know unbiased clustering of patients
and this might help us
actually do a stratification
and what would be really great is then
we can use this information once we've
kind of grouped people into
slightly more homogeneous populations
and subtypes
is then we can do the cell type directed
approach
then on each of those groups
individually so this will give us
you know disease subtype specific cell
type information
one caution here is of course if we're
already stratifying based on
cell type proportions we need to be very
careful how we use cell type proportion
information downstream we're sort of
already stacking the deck
in terms of you know making these
populations as different as possible in
terms of their cell types
proportions so you just have to be
careful about how you use that
but nonetheless i think this is a very
useful approach
okay so now for the second part i want
to take a moment
to talk about you know how
some of the challenges that we're facing
and you know
what what might need to be done before
we can really make full use of single
cell
in the ways that i've just discussed
so first how long does a single cell
rnac take
that analysis tape but i think this is
an interesting question to start off
with because this is something that
i think when people first start doing a
single cell they start planning a single
cell experiment this is not maybe what
they're thinking about
i usually warn people that it for a
single cell analysis you should budget
about two months
so it doesn't always take that long but
i find that this is actually usually a
pretty good
ballpark to make and so you know when i
say that people are often surprised
and they ask me well what takes so long
so what does take so long well to
explain this i'll go over the steps
so analysis starts with the data
pre-processing
this basically is taking the output from
that comes from the sequencer
and going through you know the steps of
aligning reads the genome and then
quantifying
different genes and um this the output
of this is under your account matrix
so at least in the case of 10x and i
think in really most single cell
technologies we have pretty good
pipelines for doing this and so this
process is really
you know it may it may actually take
some time just because
you know it takes it's a lot of data
sometimes but in terms of you know man
hours
it's really not very labor intensive and
we kind of have this step figured out
the next step is your cell quality
control and
sort of technical effect adjustment so
this step is i think absolutely critical
for a good analysis like this is
something that should not be taken
lightly
and you really need to get it right
otherwise you can greatly skew your
results
and your analysis will you know not you
know
it's a junk garbage and garbage out kind
of situation
so i say we're moving in the right
direction here in terms of being able to
do this
more quickly although it needs to be
done very carefully we now
are more and more having automated
methods that allow us to better detect
empty droplets
things like doublets um you know
adjusting for technical effects and
batch effects and so on
and so we're getting close to being able
to have this be a streamlined process
where i'd say you know dutied importance
is still a step that i take
you know very carefully and you know i
don't think it should be rushed through
but now really the step that takes the
most time
is this third step the cell type
identification and the downstream
analysis
so of course downstream analysis is
always going to be very dependent on
whatever your question is and
so in a way we you know there's no way
to kind of put that into a pipeline
right because it's always going to be
different
so the real piece i want to focus on is
cell type identification because this is
something that feels like
it shouldn't be so hard it shouldn't
take so much time and it's something we
need to do
in almost every experiment that we do
for single cell
so now you might be thinking well i've
done cell type of navigation before it
wasn't that hard
and i'll agree with you if you know if
all you care about is looking at things
on the level of
you know t cells b cells fibroblasts so
on and so forth
because in general it's true that those
cell types actually do separate
fairly well and we have good markers to
identify them
however of course there's a lot more to
cell types than that even within say
cd4t cells we have a huge diversity of
different subtypes
that might be interesting to look at but
when we try to identify those subtypes
things get a lot trickier it's simply
they simply don't separate out as nicely
as the broad cell types do
and oftentimes the markers we want to
look at to identify them
you know are just not they're not as
useful as we'd like
so this is not to say that that
information is not there that we can't
identify subtypes but simply that it's
quite difficult at times
and can be very time consuming
however i think this despite this it's
absolutely worth looking at cell types
subtypes and in fact i think actually
critical that we look at subtypes
it's been shown many times already that
even within say cd4 t
cells there are many subtypes that are
specifically involved in different
diseases
and just to give example of asthma i
think it's been shown that several
different subtypes of t
cells play important roles and actually
many other immune cell types as well as
well as the relative proportions of them
and their interactions are all important
for the disease understanding
so this is really a level of information
that we can't ignore
so you know i i want to emphasize that
i think this is definitely something
within reach subtyping
is possible it's just difficult and i'll
just give one example here
so i'm showing t and nk cells that are
from kidney biopsies of patients with
lupus nephritis
and so basically i just took this
dataset and i
tried to see how deeply i could go in
terms of subtyping
and you can see i i got a decent amount
of subtypes so we we actually can get a
pretty good amount of information here
this is going to vary a lot from data
set to data set
and it depends a lot on the data quality
as well
but i think when you have good quality
data subtyping is certainly possible
now the other piece of this though on
the flip side is that
to get to this point took me several
days of work and a lot of manual
marker examination so on and so forth
it was not simple and this was only for
the tnnk cells then i had to do it for
other cell
subtypes as well so you can see how this
process starts to take a lot of time and
when you do a lot of single cell
analyses
it's a lot of work um
but again you know i think that this is
absolutely something worth doing
it's worth the time because this whole
approach of cell types of targets that i
discuss
depends on having the right resolution
of cell type information for your
disease
if for example you know you have these
two
populations of t regs and one of them is
playing a suppressive role and the other
one has some kind of dysfunction
dysfunctional roles not behaving right
you know if you were to lump those
together
you might miss out on seeing a signal
where one of those sub cell types might
be associated with disease while the
other is not
so you really need to get down to that
right resolution in order to see the
source of signals
so i've been telling you over and over
you know cell subtype identification is
hard
um and you know i'm sure you believe me
but i think it's kind of hard to
understand
why it's so hard until you actually have
tried it yourself
so to sort of get you there a little bit
i'm going to try to walk through some
examples to demonstrate what makes this
such a challenging process
so you know a lot of the way we do cell
type identification is based on
known markers sometimes these markers
come from
you know a long history of just
understanding of and
profiling of a certain cell type so for
example for
t regs we have fox p3 as a known master
transcription factor that's involved
um and so we use this sort of
information
to help us to identify cell types so in
the case of
box p3 you know fortunately this is
reasonably well expressed
and you know we can see you know it
zeroes us in
right on what we think are the t regs
however this is not always the case for
all markers and in fact i would say
most markers actually don't behave this
well
so for example if you look at gata3 this
is another transcription factor marker
for another cell type
however you can see that it is not
specific to anything
it's being expressed all over the place
cd4 cb8 and k cells
all over um and so you know that's
clearly not helpful for cell type
identification
it's hard to know why this is occurring
um sometimes it's because
certain genes are just not specific on
the rna level whereas they might be more
specific on the protein level
or sometimes they're just really not
specific and that's just how it is
another thing that happens quite often
is that
especially for things like chemokine
receptors cytokines we see
very very few cells where we have we've
detected that gene
and this is because most likely those
genes are lowly expressed
on the rna level and with single cell
we're really only detecting
you know we can only reliably detect
usually the highest expressed genes
usually
the top 2 000 or so most highly
expressed genes depends a lot on your
technology the quality of your data and
so on but you know on average that's
usually what we see
and so these more lowly expressed genes
are just not reliably deducted
they may actually be there but we're not
going to see them in our final data
and therefore we can't really use them
to guide cell type identification
so to kind of make this even more
concrete i'm going to work through
another example with another data set so
this is
pbmcs from the 10x genomics website it's
a pretty
standard data in terms of you know
sequencing depths
um you know around 2000
genes detected per cell on average
things like that
um and so i'm going to
walk through an example of trying to
identify some t cell subtypes
so first step usually is to figure out
where
the t cells are to begin with just
overall to do this we'll look at cd3
c4 cb8 so we can see c3
showing up very clearly in the top
clusters there
which you know matches up with you know
cb4 and cba in different locations which
looks good
however you'll see right off the bat
actually cd4
is showing an interesting difference
from the rest and in fact what it turns
out is that
cd4 is expressed also in myeloid cells
which is that
large cluster near the bottom so this is
a
really clear example of a case where you
know i think most people think of c4 as
the t marker of cb4-t cells but
on the rna level at least it's expressed
quite highly in myeloid cells as well so
it cannot be used
reliably alone as a marker in that case
so once we have identified our t cells
usually what we'll do is we'll pull them
out and we'll recluster them
and the idea there is that by
re-clustering you know within just that
cell type
sometimes this helps pull apart subtypes
better because we're basically trying to
cluster just
on the variation within the t cells it
doesn't always work
but sometimes it helps a little bit so
we'll do that
and so this new plot that i'm showing is
now just the t
cells and now we'll try to identify some
subtypes
so first we'll look at t-regs t-regs are
generally
um on the easier side to identify
so i'll look here at cd4 fox p3
il-2ra which is cd25 and ctla4
so you can see although none of these
genes is completely specific
they're all kind of pointing us in the
same direction of this small cluster
near the bottom that i've circled which
are most likely to be our t-rex
so because we have information from
multiple genes we can kind of build up
confidence that that's
probably most likely the t-rex but i
think it's really
interesting to note you can see here how
you know none of these
is completely specific even box p3 um
you know there are a lot of possible
explanations for why you see expression
elsewhere
but in any case you can just see that
basically you can't just take it alone
as the ultimate predictor of t-regs and
in addition you can see
if you zoom in on the cluster you can
see not all the cells
are even expressing fox p3 so you know
it's
this is why we usually take this
clustering approach because basically
you know we can't just gate on fox v3
because you're going to have a lot of
cells that where you're not detecting it
and so
what you do is you rely on the cluster
information where we say oh well
enrichment of cells here express boxy3
therefore we're going to infer that the
rest of them probably express it as well
and that they're probably all t-regs
in any case so you know it's although
there is some
ambiguity overall this is a fairly
confident
identification of subtype
okay so then another subtype we might
want to try to identify is
th2 this is a type of t helper cell we
can look at cd4
gata3 ccr4 il4 which are you know
typical markers you might find in the
literature
all right well i already showed you guys
three which is not specific and
therefore
is not helpful here dcr4 looks a little
bit more
promising however ccr4 is actually
expressed in other subtypes of cd4 t
cells and so we can't
use it alone as a as a definitive
definitive marker h2
and then il4 has the unfortunate case of
just not being detected widely
and you know we really can't do cell
type identification based on just one
cell so unfortunately this was a failure
to identify the subtype
finally one last example i'll show is
you know trying to make this overall
broad distinction between naive effector
central memory and effector memory
t cells and so usually the way we'll do
this is
look at the combination of c45 ra
positive versus ro positive
and then cb 62l positive and negative
cells and so if we look at these genes
on the rna level
we're showing what they look like on the
bottom the cd45 you know ra and ro are
basically isoforms cd45 and
unfortunately
we just don't have that information on
the rna bubble in this case
cd62l you know maybe has a little bit of
signal here but
it's a bit messy and so it's hard to
make a clear call on what's going on
however so fortunately this is actually
a sightseeing data set so we have
information on 29 surface proteins here
which includes cd62l
and cd45ra and ro and so
now by looking at the protein level
information
we can see a much clearer picture about
where
these genes are actually being expressed
on the surface
um and so this allows us to actually
make a
reasonably confident prediction about
what what
these different subtypes where they are
in this cluster
plot um so i think
you know i think sightseek and really
just you know
methods that can bring in this sort of
protein information
are going to be really really helpful
for doing cell subtype identification
going forward and there are even methods
that are being developed now
that that will allow you to combine the
surface protein information with the rna
information at the same time
and do a joint sort of clustering on
both of those pieces of information
which generally results in you know more
clearly defined clusters
which makes the whole process a lot
easier
all right so you might be thinking uh
well what about automated cell type
identification
so i think this is a really exciting
area and something i've been
paying a lot of attention to um i i do
hope that someday this will be
the answer to this question however
at least right now i have yet to see
evidence that
automated annotation is ready for prime
time so
i think the figure that i'm showing here
really illustrates that so this is from
a
recent benchmarking of cell type
automated cell type
identification methods that came out in
2019
one thing i should say is you know this
field is moving very quickly so already
a paper from 2019 is probably quite out
of date
so there may be improvements here
however you know what i want to direct
your attention to
is in this plot so they're showing the
performance of various different methods
on different tests
and you can see if you look at the inter
data set
test and then look at the deep
annotation level so right in the middle
that column you can see across the board
all methods are doing very poorly on
this test so basically in other words
when you try to use one training set
to classify a completely separate
separate test set
that's the enter data set test method
and then try to do this on a deep
annotation level so subtypes
no method is able to handle that right
now again
there may be improvements since this
paper but basically this is where
all the method this is a real pain point
right now
so we've tested several methods in-house
and you know including um svm method
which was the top performer in this
benchmark as well as
the threat transfer anchor approach
which we found also performed
almost identically with svm and so what
we've
basically replica replicated this
finding where basically we when we test
we build the classifier based on pvmcs
and then test on pbmcs
we see good performance but then when we
try to
generalize this to another dataset it's
a bit of a mess
so for example i'm showing here that
same classifier that was trained on
pvmcs but now applied to the human
kidney atlas
dataset so this contains um
so i'm showing here the cd45 positive
cells so you can see that they're
basically a lot of non-immune cells in
this dataset from the kidney
and of course you know our pbmc
classifier doesn't know anything about
non-immune cells so it's not going to be
able to classify them
however we would expect that because we
have a threshold on
probability for classification or
basically anything that isn't high
confidence enough
we mark as unclassified one would hope
that all of this
other non-immune stuff would be
classified would be
marked as unclassified however this is
not the case what we see
is basically these things are all being
classified as t cells and apparently
quite confidently because otherwise they
wouldn't have passed that threshold
so this is you know unfortunate i guess
not maybe not too unexpected because
you know this is a very difficult
problem to try and generalize to a
completely different context
one ray of hope i see is that at least
for the cell types that were in common
between the training and testing
we see reasonably good performance it's
not 100
but it's it's fairly good so i think you
know there's promise here but what we
really need are
you know either methods that can really
do a good job generalizing to new
contexts
or we need better reference data sets so
that we can have
you know the right reference for any new
data set that comes up
i think a combination of those two
things is where we're going to be
heading in the future
so then this question of you know
automation overall
are we there yet i see because single
cell analysis takes so long there's
always this urge to try and automate it
to make it faster
i want to urge caution here you know i
think basically we're at a point where
yes
certain steps can be automated without
too much trouble
but others you really need to be
cautious
like i mentioned you know the initial
steps of data pre-processing
is not really a big issue to automate
we're getting closer for the cell qc and
technical effect adjustment methods
however you know when you get the cell
type identification um i think in most
cases unless you're doing a very
you know um you know even if even if
you're doing pbmc to pbmc type of
automated classification
you still need to be careful and check
those results in a manual way because
it's just really important to get those
things right because you know all of
your downstream analysis depends on it
so you know i i would say this is still
an area where
you know even if you use a manual
automated method to supplement
you still need to do manual review
hopefully we're on our way though
to getting to automation here
okay and so you know just looking
forward um i see
a lot of challenges that we're going to
have to face as a field i already
mentioned automated cell type
identification
another big one i see is large-scale
integration you know a lot
we do have integration methods now
however um
you know the integrated and corrected
data account uh tables that were
produced by this
are not really appropriate for
downstream analyses so we need to think
about ways that we can actually
ask questions across large compendiums
of data
that way we can actually make use of all
the signals of data that's being
generated
and not be limited to just looking at
one study at a time
i'm also really excited about
multi-omics integration but like i
mentioned
you know integrating surface protein
information can be hugely helpful for
cell type identification
and there are many other types of single
cell omics that can be done as well so
single phallic atoxique
so on and so forth and all of these can
be potentially integrated together
to give a better full picture of what's
going on in the cell
we're also going to have to think about
scaling up of course especially if we're
thinking about looking across many
different studies
many different types of omics data
together
there's going to be definite scaling
issues that start occurring
i think you know if we want to make use
of all the data that's going to come out
of human cell atlas these are challenges
we're going to have to start thinking
about
so with that i hope i've given you a
good overview of how single cell rna-seq
can be useful for drug discovery as well
as disease understanding in general
as well as you know some of the
challenges we're currently facing and
you know where
where the field is hopefully moving
towards so
with that i'm happy to take any
questions
thank you dr middleton for that amazing
and
informative presentation we'll now start
the live q a portion of the webinar
and if you have a question you'd like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for
so let's get started dr middleton our
first question
is the single cell level data
for every gene does not have that high
quality
with a lot of zeros while doing an
in-depth analysis
how do you bypass this while making sure
the analysis is correct
and the second part do you perform any
kind of
imputation as well
yeah so this is a really good question
and something we pretty much always have
to deal with
with single cell is that we're not going
to see information
on all of the rnas that are there
so i personally
do not use imputation at this time um i
think
that this is something that in certain
situations might be useful but i think
it needs to be used carefully because
you're essentially introducing smoothing
over your data
and depending on what you'd like to do
that may or may not be
an ideal thing to do i think
possibly potentially with subtypes in
particular
that might be problematic if you end up
you know kind of smoothing away this
more
rare subpopulation you may actually not
see it as clearly
if i i should say though you know i
haven't experimented with that
personally so i can't say for sure
exactly how it behaves
um an important thing to note with
you know the missing data problem kind
of with single cell is
especially when you think about target
discovery you know you
if you are directly comparing um
between healthy disease what what's
changing and you're using single cell
data you know you're only going to see
um changes in genes that you actually
detect right and so you're introducing
bias into your target discovery where
you're only looking at the most highly
expressed genes
and this is a pretty big bias you know
you're and that's only like 2 000 genes
that you're looking at
uh i think to some extent the focusing
on cell types first can
alleviate this a little bit because you
know you you first figure out the cell
type hypothesis
and then you can also look at
on a whole what's going different in
that cell type on the pathway level
and then maybe you can infer well any
gene in this pathway
is probably relevant and so hopefully
you know you can
use that to generalize to more than what
you've actually detected
uh you can you can apply this of course
as well with just doing
direct differential expression between
health and disease um
so i think approaches like that are
important
when thinking about the drug discovery
aspect of this um
but overall i think you know dropouts
and
just missing like you know lower quality
data are things that we just have to
deal with with single cell
on a case-by-case basis because it's
often quite different for every data
dataset
wonderful thank you so much for that so
our next question
what would you say are the most common
bias when interpreting these types of
data
right so um there are a lot of different
biases
that come with single cell rna-seq and i
think we just talked about
um the problem of you know detecting the
most highly expressed genes right so
you have a bias there um another thing
that can come in
with cell types especially so when
thinking about
cell type proportions um you know not
all cell types
are equally well captured in single cell
so some
don't survive well during the
dissociation process if you're working
with let's say a tissue
it depends a lot on the technology
you're using but there's
been many times shown actually with
different tissues
that certain cell types are being kind
of selected against when you do single
cell
and this is potentially very problematic
if you're relying on cell type
proportions
for information about the disease
so there are certain situations where
doing
nuclear sequencing can help with this so
this has been done to some extent in
kidney for example
because it's basically been shown that
that helps with detection of certain
cell types
gives you kind of a slightly more
representative sampling
so i think this is something that's
going to vary again you know depending
on your sample and what you're doing so
it it's something to keep in mind
thank you we have we do have time for a
few more questions i do want to remind
our audience that the questions that
we're unable to answer today
and those that come in during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
our speaker via the email address that
you've
provided at the time of registration so
dr middleton moving on to our next
question
regarding the changes in cell type
proportion on
sc rna-seq don't you think that the
stochastic that comes from the sampling
of cells
that end up being sequences make the
proportion
not trustable at all yeah okay so
that's a great point so there is
absolutely a lot of
heterogeneity and because of the issues
i just talked about there can be
variability and what cell types are sort
of
being you know captured well from
experiment to experiment is something
subject to batch effects
so you end up with perhaps a pretty
large amount of variability insult-type
proportion
from people and maybe if you sample the
same person twice you know you'd see
something slightly different every time
um and you know on top of this this can
also be if you're sampling from a
heterogeneous tissue
the actual location you sample from will
affect what cell type proportions you
you get out and really i think the best
way to
address this if this is the approach you
want to take is to sample a lot of
people
the more samples you have the more
confidence you can have you know
the more power basically you have to
detect differences between groups
and so this is the approach i would
recommend and in general i think
having larger sample sizes in terms of
biological replication so
you know additional donors um is
one of the most important things you can
do to improve your single cell analysis
because
there is a lot of variability no matter
what you do and
so having more biological replication on
donor levels so not talking about more
cells but more donors
is really the level of replication that
you need to address that
so that's what i would recommend to to
just help
you to deal with this very this kind of
unavoidable variability
so it looks like we have time for maybe
one or two more questions
so here's our next one regarding
automated cell type identification
and the most of cells being annotated
uh is because some methods like sera
anchoring
actually don't have a threshold for the
probabilities and it assigns the highest
probability as the labels
even if it's for example 0.3
yeah so i think that is the default
behavior of the transfer anchor approach
what we what we did in the analysis i
showed was we had
added an additional probability filter
on top
so you know we basically filtered it
such that
i think i forget the exact probability
threshold that we use so basically
if it was below that threshold we called
it unclassified
and so this was happening despite that
and i if i remember correctly it was
quite a high probability threshold like
0.9 or something like that so really
you know they these cells are being
pretty confidently identified as t cells
which was surprising to me
and it was difficult with raising that
threshold to get to a point where
you know we were um correctly marking
those unclassified without having too
much of a
negative effect on our sensitivity for
the cell types that you know we
were actually able to annotate so
there's a trade-off there
um and you know just adding the
um the threshold is not enough to
address it at the time
you know like i said though there's a
lot of ways we can improve upon this
we can have a better reference set you
know if we use the kidney
dataset as a reference i have no doubt
that this would perform a bit better
um the key point though really is just
um
you know even with better performance i
think this is still something we need to
be
careful with at the moment because you
know the performance is not 100
and you want to make sure that your cell
type annotations are as accurate as
possible
wonderful thank you dr middleton for
that answer so we've got
a couple more minutes so we can squeeze
one more question in
assuming that we have three single cell
rna sequencing data sets
after we do the clustering on the first
batch can we use the other two batches
to validate the clustering result
and how can we do that okay so
i'm interpreting this as
you have done annotation on one
and you want to apply this
to the other data sets i'm not sure if
i'm interpreting the question correctly
um i mean so one way to do this is
basically yeah i mean you can use
you so you could um you know annotate
each one separately
and then try the transfer anchor
approach and see if the annotations you
get by transferring one to the other
are accurate and then that you know that
accuracy level should
generalize for more batches within that
particular
study that you're doing assuming you
know nothing changes too dramatically
so you can do that to sort of give
yourself some confidence
for your annotation i think that would
be a pretty nice approach and
really there's no better reference for
automated annotation than another sample
from your same study
um of course i would recommend using
multiple samples not just one
but uh you know that's going to be
that's probably going to give you the
most accurate results overall
thank you so much dr middleton um do you
have any final comments for our audience
no no no nothing in particular thank you
very much for this opportunity to talk
and you know i'm happy to follow up um
more you can
find my you know contact me on linkedin
or if my email
address is posted here somewhere but i'm
happy to talk
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information that you
provided
at the time of registration we would
like to once again thank dr middleton
for her time today
and her important research we would also
like to thank leopards and our sponsor
10x genomics for underwriting today's
educational webcast
you can view the webinar on demand
labberts will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
that's all for now thank you again for
joining us and until next time
bye bye everyone